what's going on guys this is rob and as
i have always told you guys when it
comes to this channel when any of you
guys come up with a really really cool
theory that i like i like to make sure
that i give you guys credit and one of
you all somebody named green light me
had this really cool idea now they said
they saw an early script of the movie um
i wouldn't take this as an absolute
truth i'm not calling you a lie or i'm
simply just saying that in this day and
age there's so many leaks and rumors out
there that have been debunked or
confirmed there's no real way to know
what's actually true or false until we
sit down and we see the movie however
i love this so i want to run over this
and then i actually want to talk about
it as we go through these various
portions here so what they said is that
max dillon electro is the first one to
be pulled in to the marvel cinematic
universe when the whole spell with
spider-man basically goes awry and he's
pulled into the marvel cinematic
universe after he's electrocuted in the
amazing spider-man but before he falls
into the vat of eels which kind of makes
sense because he basically gets
electrocuted then he starts falling and
so it would make sense like a portal
would open up under him and he would
land in the mcu now from what green
light me said he lands in a fountain in
new york and for the most part it seems
really weird that he was suddenly
transported to a new location doesn't
really seem to know exactly what's going
on but new york doesn't look that
different from new york in his universe
so he just ends up kind of rolling with
it now i would argue that what makes
this interesting is this seems to fly in
the face of how elektro got his powers
in the first place because remember max
dillon was electrocuted and then fell
into the vat of eels and then was bitten
by electric eels but it wasn't until he
was bitten by the eels that he started
to change right his skin started to
adjust and he became the electro that we
saw in the amazing spider-man and so
what that always seemed to indicate to
me is that him being electrocuted just
kind of knocked him into the water and
set the stage for the electric eels
biting him to basically turn him into
electro to kind of channel their
electrical energy into him and then turn
him into the villain that he ended up
becoming now green light me goes on to
say that following his arrival in the
marvel cinematic universe that he simply
just like adjusts his look gets a
haircut and then tries to blend in there
isn't really any explanation in terms of
how he basically navigates this new
universe that he's in i would go as far
as to say that when you look at the new
york skyline as a whole assuming we
leave out like avengers tower because
that's kind of gone through a few things
if you guys recall it was stark tower
initially then it was rebranded as
avengers tower and then after the events
or really during the events of civil war
that basically was sold off and then
ultimately the avengers moved to upstate
new york and that more recently during
spider-man far from home it was being
remodeled so leading that whole thing
out when you look at the nature of the
new york skyline between like 2013 which
is when the amazing spider-man 2 took
place and
2024 which is when spider-man no way
home takes place
you're not going to see a massive
difference new york's overall skyline
doesn't change that much smaller
buildings will but not the entire
skyline itself more so than that maxwell
dylan while he was a little socially
awkward was not an idiot like he was
pretty intelligent so i would have to
imagine that just by virtue of being
teleported to a new place and just kind
of being like what in the world is going
on here he would probably figure out
pretty fast that he's in a different
universe not his native universe now
what kind of things transpire as he
explores that i don't really know but i
could definitely see that happening
pretty easily now following this and
this is when things get really really
interesting green light me says that the
next two people to arrive are dr octopus
and then the green goblin right so
electro first doc ock second green
goblin third and that is actually dr
strange that helps spider-man capture
doctor octopus and the green goblin and
so the capturing of dr octopus probably
takes place in that scene or around that
scene from the trailer when he basically
gets his hands on peter parker and then
he says like you're not peter right when
tom holland unmasked himself you guys
all know that really popular scene that
like everybody's talking about because
it's so exciting and so with that being
the case i could easily see where like
dr strange shows up around that time or
he and spider-man were working together
whatever the case is and basically
doctor octopus and the green goblin are
captured now what green light me also
goes on to say is that that particular
scene where you see doctor strange push
peter parker his essence or his kind of
spiritual form out of his body that's
the whole scenario that leads to him
basically freeing dr octopus and the
green goblin by accident what's also
kind of interesting here is it looks
like electro never actually gets
captured in the box by doctor strange
instead while that whole thing is going
on with doc ock and the green goblin
being captured by doctor strange and
spider-man electro's out there doing his
own thing what it is that he's doing is
really intriguing because according to
green light me it comes from a character
that i imagine most of us forgot about
or never even considered in the first
place now what's important here is that
in our video where we talked about what
was going on with electro and star tech
and all that kind of stuff that we we
kind of created this argument that time
has passed right that it doesn't just
happen over the course of like a few
days that some period of time is passing
here and green light me really kind of
confirms that in his theory right where
he basically says the whole thing takes
place over the course of six weeks and
so where doctor octopus and apparently
green goblin are freed by peter parker
they ultimately end up tracking down
electro now this part of the theory is
one that i'm not 100 sure i'm on board
with it seems kind of hokey and kind of
lame but they basically convince electro
to work with them in order to stay in
the mcu because apparently if it goes
back to his own universe he'll end up
turning into blue electro i would go as
far as to argue that whether they
overheard it or they were even just told
directly that they're aware of the
statement dr strange made to peter
parker which is they're destined to die
fighting their own spiderman and so that
would likely be their motivation for
staying in the mcu if i'm being honest i
don't really think that dr octopus or
green goblin would care
that if elektra went back to his own
universe that he would look like a bag
of cool ranch doritos i don't think it
really matters to them all that much but
i could definitely see them wanting to
work with him to stay in their universe
or in the marvel cinematic universe so
they're basically not guaranteeing their
own demise by going back to their own
universe this is where things get really
really interesting and really cool
because looking at the trailer one of
the things that we've all kind of
noticed and multiple people have pointed
out is that it looks like dr octopus and
green goblin and electro those three
specifically all seem to have stark tech
and that would make sense because
they're the three individuals that need
some form of technology to utilize their
capabilities right green goblin uses
technology for the goblin glider dr
octopus uses technology for his
tentacles and electro uses technology to
channel and control his abilities and so
what seems to end up happening here
again according to green light me is
that they end up going to visit someone
that they basically end up acquiring
stark tech from and that person is not
vulture instead
it's power broker which i never would
have considered i never would have
considered the idea that sharon carter
as the power broker would be the one to
give them the kind of technology they
need to attain their goals and it makes
sense it makes perfect sense like i know
that the role of sharon carter in the
events of falcon and the winter soldier
didn't seem like a very substantial
event didn't seem like a very
substantial role but the important thing
here is that if anything was solidified
by her is that she's trying to maintain
absolute power right trying to control
make sure all things flow through her
kind of the kingpin of the major poor
world on top of that what you also have
is her disdain for shield
and seemingly the superhero community as
a whole so it wouldn't really strike me
as beyond the realm of possibility for
electro and green goblin and doc ock to
show up on the doorstep of the power
broker or to be summoned by the power
broker assuming that sharon's ability to
gain information is exactly what it was
during falcon and the winter soldier and
she by way of the various sources she
has has pretty much figured out exactly
what's going on with the spell and all
that kind of stuff that they're here
from an alternate reality and then they
kind of come together and it's like okay
i will give you start tech so long as
you promise to uphold your end of the
bargain which is to kill spider-man and
like destroy the superhero community or
something along those lines is it kind
of a flimsy line of logic sure but i do
believe there is some kind of logic
between them and power broker it seems
too great of a possibility to pass up it
just seems awesome right it would be a
great surprise where people are just
like i forgot about sharon carter the
power broker
yes of course it makes sense right it
just it seems like it's just too great
of an opportunity to pass up there now
what green light me goes on to say is
that because of the fact that each
member each one of these guys need to
operate at their peak capacity seemingly
it's in the best interest of doc ock and
green goblin to make sure electro is at
his peak capacity and so what they end
up doing is using a combination of stark
tech and seemingly something that a lot
of you guys have pointed out which is
basically the suit of whiplash from iron
man 2. they kind of frankenstein
hodgepodge it all together and that's
where elektro gets his suit from quite
literally it's designed by doc ock and
the green goblin working together to
make it the suit he needs to regulate
his powers and that's how he becomes the
yellow electro that we see in the movie
now the other thing about this is doctor
strange the question has to be asked
what's doctor strange doing in all this
and what green light me says is that
doctor strange is not actually out in
space or in the multiverse dealing with
all these different portals opening up
all over the place that instead what had
happened is that when peter and doctor
strange got into that fight which
basically led to doctor octopus and and
green goblin being freed that it also
trapped doctor strange in the 1970s
this is actually a great idea especially
if what you're wanting to do is
essentially introduce wolverine into the
mcu and i'll talk about that here in a
second but i think it's a genius idea
right to trap him there eventually he
ends up coming back but in doing so it
leads to a continued destabilization of
the multiverse and that's why venom and
that's why sandman and like the lizard
and those guys get yanked in because
doctor strange in order to travel back
to the main marvel universe
kind of has to break the multiverse a
little bit more in order to make that
happen the other part of this is that
andrew garfield and toby maguire
seemingly have also been pulled into the
mcu and a brunt of what goes on with the
movie is actually the three of them
right so tom holland toby mcguire and
andrew garfield working together to try
to find out where all the villains are
now as far as this idea of introducing
wolverine to the mcu this is one of
those fun theories that i've had for a
long long time all you really do here is
you say that because hydra had taken
over shield that they were trying to
find a way to create more captain
americas that led to them discovering
like james howard who was part of
probably a black ops team in the 1960s
working with the cia and that basically
led to them taking him along with the
rest of his team which was codenamed
team x and then essentially throwing
them into weapons plus or throwing him
into weapon x which is the tenth attempt
by essentially shield to create a new
captain america the other ones never
really worked wolverine was basically
the most successful and that he's kind
of you know doing his thing out there in
the world or something along those lines
i mean i wouldn't expect it to be a
major plot point i would expect it to be
like a reference to wolverine if they
were going to have him there at all like
do you remember in what was it uh x-men
apocalypse when like they ended up
discovering like wolverine basically
like when he was being held in like the
mountain and they were like using him as
a test subject and they had the thing
over his head like jean grey and then
like free them something akin to that
maybe just a little bit less i think
it'd be cool i'm by no means expecting
it but i think it'd be kind of
interesting there but the important
thing to grasp this is an important
thing to talk about here
this is all just a theory that green
light me had which apparently he saw a
leaked version of the script again i
don't know if that's true i don't know
if any of this is accurate we can just
kind of take this as a theory and really
nothing more until we actually see the
movie but regardless if this is actually
what happens in the film which he also
says there's like three other major
surprises that he just wouldn't spoil
again i don't know if that's true or not
but if just what he revealed over the
course of of that comment is really
what happens in the movie
it sounds great like it sounds like a
phenomenal film i'm excited to see it
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section you guys think
this is a very high likelihood of this
do you think it's
seems a little a little too far-fetched
a little too simple let me know what you
guys think but thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace